a lot of the people who were very
controversial back in the day like
Arnold Schwarzenegger was quite
controversial with his masculinity and
everything and the women now he's quite
establishment telling people to lock
down take their medicines do you think
Tate could ever get to you know in 30
years from now and he's you know an old
man in his 60s or whatever but Karma's
not establishment but as everybody gets
older the public perspective changes and
everyone I think will eventually love
Tate the way they love all those
controversial characters back in the day
do you think he could ever you know be
on the side of that